I remember the first time that I used
Norco we jump in the water with so many
colorful fish and it was unbelievable
[Music]
so since then I wanted to to repeat that
experience again
it wasn't until I turned 24 when I had
the opportunity to travel all around the
Baja California peninsula and that was
the moment that I realized that I wanted
to be an explorer
[Music]
my name is Octavio Aburto I am a
conservation biologist and a National
Geographic Explorer I am studying
mangroves mangroves are trees that live
where the ocean meets the coast and they
are special because they grow in salt
water
here in Mexico I think we have the most
beautiful mangroves in all the planets
they are not only beautiful they provide
a lot of economic benefits for coastal
communities the mangrove roots come into
the water and they form a refuge for
many many baby fish then they can live
inside these roots like a nursery it's
like a playground for them I just saw a
bigger school over snappers and a lot of
part of fish this juvenile only lived
here inside the mangroves and eventually
when they grow up they would supply the
fish markets here in La Paz City mangas
protect coastal areas against hurricanes
and erosion they also filtered water for
many coastal towns and provide essential
habitat for many species unfortunately
in the last 50 years we have lost half
of the mangroves worldwide and this is
because of Agriculture mystery farming
coastal development and pollution the
first step to help mangroves is to know
how much mangrove we have in order to
tackle this problem
my research both two techniques one is
counting everything that we have inside
the mangrove roots and the other branch
of our research is to estimate the cover
of the mangroves to estimate the
mangrove cover we we are using drones
with drone technology we are serving in
areas faster and it even is a new
perspective
[Music]
we fly at different heights and 100
meters and 10 meters and we take a lot
of images
[Music]
later we use all these images to create
a composite image that is called portal
Messiah so you can use we can use these
images not only to estimate the area
also the volume of the forest
[Music]
using all this data now we know where
are all these mangrove areas how many
animals live there and we can set
conservation priorities to protect this
beautiful
[Music]
the involvement of local communities is
essential to a stop mangrove raffle
station if they understand that these
routes protect their towns create
habitat for the fish that they sell in
the fish markets we will have not only
more mangrove in the future we will have
more economic benefits for them and for
the rest of the country mangroves
represent a very very tiny area in this
planet
but they provide a huge amount of
services for humans
so we need to protect them for the
future generations
[Music]
[Music]